eso ha sido una jornada una mañana bien
movida como lo menciona la primera
ministra lideró su primer consejo de
ministros con un nuevo gabinete que ha
sido definido como el más diverso en la
historia británica por supuesto no ha
habido anuncios pero la agenda se
concentró en la gran pregunta que tiene
el país y es el cuál es el plan que ha
diseñado el gobierno de alivios para
hogares y negocios por el incremento en
los precios de la energía que
probablemente será anunciado este jueves
también en el parlamento se da como un
hecho que el gobierno congelara los
precios de la energía hasta en dos mil
900 dólares porque se cree que un hogar
promedio puede pagar hasta cuatro mil
dólares al año en la factura de la luz y
por eso podría entonces congelarse el
monto restante el excedente será asumido
por el gobierno lo que cargará las
finanzas públicas y eso también ha sido
criticado ya por los expertos